a hiker is sharing his story of survival
after being stuck for four hours excuse
me four hours in quicksand newly
released video shows the daring rescue
in Utah Zion National Park search teams
airlifted 34 year-old Ryan Osman to
safety it happened over the weekend on a
trail known as the subway route Toni de
copal shows us how winter conditions are
putting hikers at risk Tony good morning
good morning if you're anything like me
you hear the word quicksand and you may
think of B movies and Saturday morning
cartoons but the Park Service says
freezing temperatures snow and cold
runoff can turn easy hikes into
treacherous ones and Zion has
experienced a particularly wet winter
this year creating the conditions for
potentially hazardous and dangerous
quicksand there was no chance of moving
it at all the sand it's surrounded the
whole leg and I couldn't move it Ryan
Osman was hiking Saturday with his
girlfriend Jessica McNeil when she
tripped into quicksand like this as he
helped her out his own right leg became
engulfed up to his hip the best way to
describe it would be to just standing in
a huge puddle of concrete that basically
just dries instantly with a storm coming
in McNeil who was later diagnosed with
hypothermia from the cold hiked three
hours until she found help I didn't know
if I would for sure make it out I didn't
know if I could do that hike alone ten
hours later park rangers reached osmond
but it took them another two hours to
get him out of the quicksand one guy
scraping sand away they were able to
free my leg it was probably one of the
worst pains I've ever felt they were
forced to spend the night when a winter
storm brought in four inches of
additional snow
it wasn't until Sunday that Utah
rescuers facing difficult terrain and
stormy weather repelled down a hundred
feet of cable to lift Osmond to safety
he was in water running water in a Oh up
to like his knees and so there were some
cold injuries hypothermia
plus the injuries from being stuck in
that same Sam for years hikers have been
warned to keep an eye out for quicksand
in Zion National Park it forms after an
area with lots of sand is saturated with
water making liquid mud which can trap
anyone who steps in it
quicksand can be tough to spot sometimes
appearing dry on the surface even though
it's wet underneath while Osman says he
suffered minor muscle damage he expects
to make a full recovery I wouldn't go
back and change anything or do anything
differently it was just a freak accident
that my leg hit this hole of sand Osman
says he has no plans to hike that
particular route again experienced
hikers say common spots to find
quicksand are in riverbeds and if your
foot does get stuck it's important not
to panic you slow and controlled
movements to try to loosen yourself from
the sand and I'll give you a good reason
not to panic our partners at the BBC
actually looked into the quicksand
question in 2016 and found that there is
no truth to the cartoon image of someone
sinking further if you move around a lot
doesn't generally happen the physics are
with you ya heart though someone will
come for you I would say Tony though
it's so hard not to panic I like that he
said he wouldn't do anything differently
that he he actually got in this
situation trying to help her try and
help her they're all at the end that's
good his opportunity to do anything at
all changed as soon as he got into the
quick sitting there also good advice
stay indoors yes morph anytime yeah but
at least he was trying to help her
someone on the studio who shall remain
nameless name starts with the T when he
said he wouldn't do anything differently
someone said really yes I like that guy
thank you very much